you're a member of an elite mobile task
force tracking down an anomaly in a
rural village somewhere in the swiss
alps that was recently detected by scp
foundation field agents according to all
the current intel you're dealing with a
particularly deadly and hard to contain
monster a shape-shifting entity that can
kill with a touch and assume the form of
anyone it kills if this thing somehow
escaped the village and broke into a
major population center it could blend
in perfectly and cause death on a
massive scale it's up to you and your
team to get this creature secured and
contained before that can happen you're
going in heavily armed with advanced
sensory technology and several attack
helicopters each one loaded with plenty
of powerful missiles one way or another
you're putting a stop to this thing but
the best laid plans of mobile task force
agents go often awry the mission is a
bloodbath the shape-shifting anomaly has
blended in perfectly with the innocent
civilians living in the village before
you know it half of your team have been
killed and you don't know which of the
remaining team members are really
themselves this really couldn't have
gone worse and if you mess this up not
only is your life at risk but so are the
lives of everyone this anomaly happens
to get close to all of your superiors
were killed or transformed in the battle
with a shapeshifter and you're now
sitting at the top of your mtf's chain
of command the way you see it there's
only one option you radio up to air
support alerting the several attack
choppers circling the village you tell
them to rain fire and destroy the whole
place that's the only way to be sure to
take out the anomaly things have gone
beyond the point of easy containment you
sprint past the village limits as the
volley of missiles and firebombs raise
the formerly quiet settlement to the
ground other than the task force members
in the helicopters you're the only
survivor over 320 people are dead but on
the upside the remains of the
shapeshifting anomaly were found amongst
the rubble by foundation personnel you
prevented whatever horrors it would have
caused if it had been allowed to escape
mission accomplished but it's not over
yet when you solemnly return to the
containment site you've been deployed
from your superiors order you to go pay
a visit to conference room 2. you
correctly assume that it's some kind of
disciplinary meeting maybe the site
director chewing you out for shoddy work
but ultimately congratulating you for
doing what needed to be done under
pressure after all making the tough
decisions is what working for the scp
foundation is all about but when you
arrive in the conference room you're
sitting across from a woman you've never
seen before she's tall with hard
stern-looking features and a plain but
well-tailored suit despite being a
hardened soldier on the foundation
payroll something about this woman makes
you nervous she smiles and says hello
i'm with the foundation ethics committee
we need to have a word for reasons you
don't quite understand you start to
break into a cold sweat the ethics
committee i thought they just existed to
scare foundation employees i didn't know
they had actual authority but that's
where you made a terrible mistake and
from the tight smile on the agent's face
you can tell that the foundation ethics
committee has a lot more power than
you've ever imagined perhaps you know
them from the jokes that float around
the foundation circles how many members
of the ethics committee does it take to
change a light bulb none the ethics
committee can't change anything perhaps
you heard about the o5 council's disdain
for them those bureaucratic pencil
pushers with all their rubber stamps and
red tape the jokes don't seem so funny
now though the ethics committee
representative clears her throat and
tells you that you've been reassigned
effective immediately you're now under
the employee of the foundation ethics
committee and this change is
non-negotiable you try to state your
case in blind panic part of you thinks
that being reassigned to the ethics
committee after the mistake you just
made is code for being taken into a
windowless room and shot in the back of
your head but the agent insists that
really isn't the case the ethics
committee hates codes and euphemisms
they don't say terminated they say kill
because at the ethics committee clarity
of language is extremely important they
don't sanitize any horrific acts that
need to be performed for the sake of
containment after all it's their job to
look these horrors in the face and give
the final yes or no on whether they're
carried out as you may know the scp
foundation is essentially above all
external law no government no
organization and no individual can tell
them what to do the 13 members of the o5
council have almost unlimited knowledge
at their disposal as well as technology
that the rest of the world could only
ever dream of with a setup like that it
would be easy to give in to corruption
and go mad with power if they wanted to
they could abandon their mission of
protecting humanity from the shadows and
instead rule the world with an iron fist
that's where the all-important role of
the foundation ethics committee comes in
as uncle ben once said with great power
comes great responsibility just as the
o5 council wields the power the ethics
committee wields the responsibility they
remind the whole organization that they
are here to serve the world not the
other way around think of them as the
conscience of the scp foundation they
decide what's morally acceptable for the
foundation to do in pursuit of its goals
to make sure that those who fight
monsters don't become monsters
themselves as nietzsche famously said if
you gaze long into an abyss the abyss
also gazes into you right now you very
much feel like you're staring into the
abyss as the ethics committee
representative calmly explains the
situation to you an important thing to
remember about the foundation is that it
must be cold not cruel the second that
the harm it causes is in excess of the
positive results of the foundation's
actions it's time for the ethics
committee to step in and dole out some
discipline it is the ethics committee's
job to balance the moral cost of every
action performed by the foundation from
the degree of collateral damage
permissible in the field to the ways
that d-classes can be ethically used in
testing while some hardcore foundation
loyalists may say that people like the
ethics committee are standing in the way
of true progress giving yourself wholly
to the mission without any ethical
safeguards can be a dangerous line to
walk at that point what's separating the
foundation from the global occult
coalition or the chaos insurgency or
even worse their nightmarish alternate
cells from the universe of
scp-1730 and scp-5000
while the foundation occasionally needs
to do some truly horrific things in
order to secure contain and protect it
is the ethics committee that keeps them
on the moral high ground all of this
seems pretty complicated to you as you
sit still fearing for your life in
conference room 2. the ethics committee
agent explains that it's actually all
quite simple once you get used to it the
ethics committee uses a moral framework
known as utilitarianism think of it like
the product of morality and math
specifically the committee uses an
ethical system known as negative
utilitarianism this system revolves
around the principle of harm reduction
the committee tries to modify every
action taken to cause the least amount
of possible suffering in a situation the
goal being to eliminate any unnecessary
suffering from action take your decision
for example the ethics committee
representative says your actions namely
the destruction of the village caused a
great deal of suffering however
considering the damage the anomaly could
have caused after your team lost control
of the situation it's clear that your
motivation was ultimately pure harm
reduction i admire that kind of thinking
in a high pressure situation you feel a
cool wave of relief wash over you it
feels safe to assume at this point that
this probably isn't just a big front for
your immediate termination the agent
sitting across from you seems to sense
that that's what you're thinking and
assures you that she's being nothing but
honest with you the ethics committee has
no need to be petty they know everything
after all and that's not an exaggeration
their clearance is basically the
equivalent to level 5 the highest in the
foundation every line ever redacted from
an scp foundation file they were privy
to every secret the foundation has ever
kept they have absolute access to and
every decision the foundation has ever
made the ethics committee has always had
the final say with veto power even over
the o5 council and most importantly all
members of the ethics committee are
former foundation personnel site
directors researchers mobile task force
operatives all people whose decisions
have caused pain and death much like
jury duty the responsibility is random
and non-negotiable what you're
experiencing right now isn't a normal
disciplinary hearing it's an employee
orientation the cruel irony for a
department of the foundation devoted to
ethical conduct is that it's actually
complicit in pretty much all of the
foundation's worst moral crimes after
all every action that the foundation has
ever performed has been performed with
the permission and cooperation of the
ethics committee take the infamous
procedure 110 montauk used to prevent
the victims of scp-231 giving birth the
ethics committee had a key role in
designing the horrific procedure
and now they have to live with the
soul-crushing knowledge of exactly what
that procedure entails and soon you will
too just one of the many perks of
joining the committee it isn't the
easiest job the representative tells you
she's got the steely blank eyes of
someone who has seen some things that
people were never meant to see she
continues before we conclude the first
part of your orientation i suppose i
should tell you about the sowing circle
that'll give you a good idea of what
you're in for she tells you that the
sowing circle was the anomaly discussed
in the 2017 ethics committee round table
it's an anomaly so secretive that it was
never given an official containment
number or classification but it was
proposed as a solution to one of the
foundation's most nightmarish problems
the shortage of human infants it is an
ugly truth about the foundation that a
decent number of anomalies such as
scp-2845 the deer require the sacrifice
of live children as part of their
containment procedures for years the
foundation has been stealing children
from orphanages for the use in these
rituals but the selling circle could
solve this problem it was a mummified
human corpse wreathed in the circle of
its own dried out intestines the mummy
produced seeds which if consumed could
allow human women to produce litters of
twelve babies with an eight hour
gestation period like the litters of a
sow hence the name this would solve the
baby shortage handily it was the job of
the ethics committee to decide what
would be the most ethical way to use
this anomaly in the end despite their
own personal moral disgust at the
actions their philosophy of harm
reduction led them to one conclusion
using the device to impregnate already
brain dead patients effectively turning
them into comatose infant factories
whose only purpose was to be used in
horrific containment procedures but
ultimately the sacrifice would pale
compared to the pain averted seeing as
millions if not billions would be under
threat from some of these entities being
released not that this makes the
knowledge of what needs to be done any
easier to handle on a personal level but
of course after what you did at the
village you know this feeling all too
well already the pain and the guilt you
felt at making that decision is going to
follow you your whole life and now
you're about to have countless more
experiences piled on top it's your
burden your duty your job the ethics
committee agent forces a weak smile she
says of course nobody said the job was
easy but somebody needs to do it now
check out
scp-001 the scarlet king and secret
group that runs the world scp-05 council
explained for more scp foundation deep
lore